what did you learn about parenting that
was so this was something that i'd seen
previously in a discussion and then to
have it brought up in the data again was
so interesting
yeah so
uh the overall effects
of parents are like ways
less than everybody thinks uh and the
size of that are twins and adoptees
so if you like see
you know identical twins adopted by
different parents they turn out
shockingly similar and then
uh
uh and then
uh people
adopted to the same parents end up not
that similar at all but then so like uh
so
uh parents in general matter very very
little but there is evidence that the
neighborhood you live in matters a lot
uh
basically they've looked at tax records
and
uh compared and people who grow up in
certain neighborhoods just do way better
and they've done all this clever math to
prove that it's really cause causally
certain neighborhoods are making them
better and the big predictor of that
interestingly
is the adults in that neighborhood so
like adults that fill out a lot of
census forms
if if you like live on a block with
adults that live fill out a lot of
census forms your kids way more likely
to have good outcomes and you're kind of
like what the hell
like that's the randomest thing in the
world it's basically like good
responsible adults
uh similarly if girls move to
neighborhoods with lots of female
scientists they're more likely to become
uh scientists themselves uh so like one
of the lessons i took from the data is
you can outsource parenting a little bit
like when you tell your kids to do
something they're just gonna probably
rebel against you because
you know a lot of people think their
parents are like
the least cool people on the planet
but
your friends they're gonna think they're
pretty cool
probably like if i think of my parents
friends all them like yeah those are you
know there were periods where i thought
my dad was pathetic and the biggest
loser and whatever but his friends are
always like yeah
they're awesome so basically you just
gotta you just gotta pick friends that
you want your kids to turn out to be
like and put them in front of your kids
uh and that you may be shocked by how
much an impact uh these people are
having on your kids it's so interesting
the fact that the people that you live
next door to
are potentially gonna have a bigger
impact on your children than you do yeah
yeah yeah it's weird it's wild
not even their kids right not even that
it's not don't worry about oh well such
and such his son is a he's a bit of a
naughty boy and he doesn't really listen
in class and it's like yeah but his
dad's cool as [ __ ] and he's a
millionaire go like just let little
timmy go and play with him a lot
yeah it reminds me of i don't know if
you saw the book uh
if you read the book rich dad poor dad
yeah by robert kiyosaki
yeah yeah that's exactly that that his
life was transformed by meeting this guy
who he thought was way cooler than his
dad could it not be like cool dad uncool
dad that might just be it
yeah yeah uh and yeah and then and then
like that transformed his life but
instead of kind of this traditional
narrow path that he thought he was
supposed to take of getting a lot of
college degrees and like working for the
government he wanted to become an
entrepreneur like his uh his rich dad
his friend's dad so i didn't think about
that well what about that what about if
his dad had been the rich dad and his
friend's dad had been the poor dad
robert would have probably grown up to
be poor because he would have listened
to the wrong person yeah
yeah yeah yeah it's interesting to think
about i mean
yeah i don't know yeah it's it can't
exaggerate the extent of this you know
some parents definitely do have big
impacts on their kids and sometimes kids
do think their parents are really cool
but i think uh you know that i think the
parents are polarizing figures for kids
whereas like the neighbors tend to be
universally
uh kind of cool like now even looking
back on it like the parents in my
neighborhood who i know weren't cool
like when i was a kid i thought they
were really cool and cooler than my dad
like uh you know like one one guy he was
just such a showoff he wasn't even a
good basketball player but he just like
constantly be dribbling the ball between
his legs and doing like weird moves and
i'm like now looking back on him like
that guy was pathetic like trying to
impress 10 year olds with his terrible
basketball moves but the time i'm like
this guy's amazing maybe that's why i
want to be a basketball player because i
grew up near this guy this lame
basketball guy what's happening people
if you enjoyed that then press here for
the full unedited episode and don't
forget to subscribe
peace